I am very pleased to have John Brownstein,
chief innovation officer at Boston Children's speak here today.
I'm Paul Vargas.
I'm the clinical lead for a health informatics for verily.
And um,
I'm going to give you a brief introduction to the doctor Brownstein.
Uh,
he's a computational epidemiologist trained at Yale University and he's also a
professor of medicine at Harvard Medical School.
Uh,
author of over 200 scientific articles.
And in 2015 he became the chief innovation officer at Boston Children's hospital
where he leads a team of 40 clinicians,
software engineers,
product managers,
et Cetera,
where they actually push the envelope on how technology is used in healthcare.
I first met John when I was a biomedical informatics fellow at Harvard Medical
School and uh,
we invited him to give us a talk that we still speak about today.
And that's because these were the,
some of the topics and terms that John talked to us about his research.
So yes,
he talked about using geostationary satellites to use image recognition to
evaluate how well Ebola corn genes were done.
He also talked about investigating crowdsourcing of black market drug prices
using dark web.
And Silk Road and it included what I feel is the single best combination of
strange abbreviations,
the World Health Organization who,
Dea Drug Enforcement Agency,
FDA food and Drug Administration.
I my personal favorite Fml,
which I am not going to explain it,
but uh,
John has been a colleague and mentor of mine and we were so impressed with his
work as fellows.
We were not the only ones who were interested in talking to John.
Uh,
this is an article about John from CNBC.
When big tech companies want to get in health,
they call this Harvard researcher.
And so,
um,
Google did to,
that's his back in 2015 and when Google flu trends,
uh,
needed to be handed over to somebody who could extend the work,
that's John and his team.
Um,
Uber is working with John.
He'll talk a little bit about his work.
We had non emergent medical transport,
but uh,
maybe John can tell us a little bit about how this happened.
I heard it will involve the text to Uber,
um,
about suggesting they get into healthcare.
Uh,
John is also known as one of the people,
uh,
who has popularized the notion of the digital phenotype.
Uh,
with the ubiquity of technology in our lives today,
we can leave a lot of clues about our health state in the interactions that we
have.
We had the internet,
social media,
et Cetera,
and John has been on the forefront of how we can harness what we consider
nontraditional healthcare information to get a better understanding of the
patient's state of health or disease.
John is always really good at predicting where the puck's going to be and I can
say that because he's from Montreal,
so he,
uh,
knows hockey.
John is on the forefront of how do we use other forms of technology to advance
health care.
And that includes voice activation of applications in health and uh,
that's the buildup.
John Stock,
which is digital phenotyping in the future of healthcare.
Please welcome John Brownstein.
All right,
great.
Thanks Paul.
Very nice introduction.
Really appreciate it.
It's great to be here.
Um,
in many ways a Google's like been a sort of a connection and collaborator since
I started in research.
Um,
and the Boston area about 15 years ago been actually intersecting with Google
sort of all parts actually.
And I'll be giving you a bunch of examples of how we've worked together.
And so many of the concepts,
they're not super foreign to this group because much of it is drawn from sort of
insights that you've been collecting throughout the years and ideas that have
been driven through the understanding of how consumer tech is changing the
landscape of healthcare.
And that's been really the thesis of the work that I've been involved in is
like,
well,
what is changing on the consumer landscape?
How do we start to bring some of that technology to understand the health of
populations,
improve access to care and understand a disease outcomes in this concept of the
digital phenotype,
which is this idea that all the data that we generate in our day to day lives
actually can provide meaningful information about us and collectively about
populations.
Um,
and so I'll give you a sort of,
um,
a level setting of why we started looking at nontraditional datasets.
So this is,
um,
a graph of myocardial infarctions,
heart attacks across the partners healthcare system.
That's actually not a count,
it's a communal cumulative sum.
But,
um,
what we noticed over a,
over a 10 year period as we saw this massive increase in heart attacks and
merging in the early two thousands.
And what's interesting,
and you know,
it doesn't prove causality necessarily,
but we had the introduction of Vioxx right around that time that we started
seeing that increase,
that increased,
went away with the withdrawal of that drug.
And we,
we did much validation off of this through my medical records and showed that
there was really a connectivity between,
through the increase of expected heart attacks across the partner system and the
prescription of,
of this medication.
And we weren't looking at this prospectively,
this was all retrospective data,
but it tells us that,
you know,
there's all this mass amount of healthcare data that's being collected that
we're not using any real appropriate weight inform our decisions.
And there's a lot of reasons for that.
And mostly because data siloed people own it.
They don't sort of shared in ways to sort of optimize the care of their health
of their populations and more broadly in public health.
At the same time,
we know that we're generating huge amounts of data across all sorts of aspects
of,
of the patient,
whether it's their phenotype data,
their genotype data across their interactions with health systems.
There's all this information that's being generated by not really used in any
way that is valuable for the patient or at least not optimized for that patient.
We often turn to geographic information systems.
I mean obviously the,
uh,
the veterans of the Google map,
of course there's a deep understanding of the fact that data layers,
um,
are a connected by their latitude and longitude and we create a very
comprehensive of a physical area based on that in interaction between a Latin
lung.
Similarly,
you know,
and this is what we're trying to do at uh,
at Harvard and many groups are doing across the world now is thinking about
trying to organize patient data across sort of that identify or to get all that,
those layers of information to get the most insight we can and of course do that
across populations to get new insights.
So that's really the,
the ideal state of the world.
But of course it's really challenging again because of these siloed sets of data
that exists.
And again,
many of the groups here are thinking about how,
how to unlock the potential of these datasets at the same time.
And,
and Paul mentioned that I took over as chief innovation officer at Boston
Children's.
We're really thinking about how to better use the data that we have about
patients to help make better informed decisions.
And you know,
it's always funny to talk to an audience like this that understands the idea of
using data to drive decisions.
We do this and you do this across all the products that you have and news and
entertainment and travel.
But that just doesn't exist in healthcare because of the reasons,
because of lack of data,
because of lack of,
of,
of an ecosystem.
That's,
it's leveraging that information to help around decisions then,
and again,
that has changed.
But if you look at other industries and um,
it's funny again to bring this up to you,
but of course the industries that have now been displaced by new companies of
course are the ones that are thinking about how to better use data about
individuals and collectively make better assessments to then provide better
feedback and better decisions.
So super clear to you in this room,
not necessarily super obvious to healthcare.
And it's been really beating this drum for many years to understand how to,
how to make this work in a healthcare setting.
So one clear example of I can go onto my,
uh,
my app on my phone and see the current temperature,
see what the forecast looks like.
And that's done because you know,
very clearly there are massive datasets being made available by organizations
like Noaa,
uh,
that make large datasets available in real time via Api.
If you start to think about,
you know,
why this doesn't exist in healthcare,
it's super clear.
There is no underlying dataset.
There's no API and there's no therefore no ecosystem of applications that lets
you understand what's happening at the individual level or across populations.
So we've been trying to solve for this issue for a number of years and in fact
had been working with Google for many years to think about how to solve for
that.
The first project that we did in this space with actually started well over 10
years ago called health map.
And we had this idea that,
you know,
just as Google mashups were,
were becoming something that people were going turning to,
why couldn't you go to a map and understand what was happening with the health
of populations?
And specifically my background is in infectious disease.
So why couldn't you go and see what outbreaks are happening,
where the risks to populations who goes around the world.
And in fact actually wrote an email to the,
what was google.org at the time and said like,
listen,
you can start to scrape the web and get insights just by mining news and social
media and blogs and chat.
All of a sudden now you can paint a picture in real time of what's happening
around the world in ways that you couldn't.
If you just went to the WHO website,
which may be posts,
you know,
couple of dozen outbreaks a year on their website.
It doesn't give you this comprehensive view of every disease event that a an
individual might be worried about or a clinician should know about in in the
care of a patient or actually a ministry of Health to understand what's
happening even in their own country or maybe in adjacent bordering countries.
So my first grant actually ever was actually out of google.org where we started
building this technology to the point where now this is not only sort of an add
on or something I think people think about,
but it's core data now that's feeding many organizations,
intelligence gathering operations ranging from CDC to who now we're in the non
traditional data sets.
Like how could you think about news or social media as being valuable healthcare
Dataset?
Well,
the first signs of h one n one if you guys remember swine flu didn't come from a
report coming out of the Ministry of health or from CDC.
It came out of a news site talking about a mysterious illness and Vera Cruz,
Mexico about an a a town that had over 50% illness,
a flu like symptoms.
That was the first sign of h one n one but more importantly,
this idea that you could start mining the web for all these breadcrumbs of data.
Um,
both at the population and individual level meant that you could actually track
a virus as it moved around the world in real time.
And that's not something that ever been done before.
Just based on the fact that you could just mind all this existing free data.
Um,
this wasn't information that was held on by any particular government.
This was data that was out there but just hadn't been processed,
hadn't been tagged,
had,
you know,
there was no NLP or machine learning tools to organize that content.
Once you could do that and then all of a sudden now you have insights that were
never made available for if you fast forward now just for instance the emergence
of Ebola that happened in a few years ago.
We have this idea now that there's actually,
you know,
you could start mining even in resource poor settings from sources of physicians
on the ground and are other organizations in a way that you could start to
actually build realtime view at a local level of what was taking place with this
really,
um,
you know,
massively important outbreak.
But beyond that you can start to integrate other data sources.
So for instance,
transportation network data.
So I want to layer in the movements of,
of,
of individuals via passenger itinerary data.
All of a sudden now you can look at the risk of introduction of,
of,
of this virus Ebola virus,
uh,
just by integrating that Dataset.
Similarly with the emergence of Zika,
people are familiar with that and seek emerged,
um,
also across a huge geography.
You can never tie any particular governments data to understanding that vast
movement.
This is from the mining of all this underlying data,
data from Twitter and other sources where people were confirming cases as they
emerged.
So this concept of,
of mining and the mining,
all this information is,
uh,
has of course evolved over in initially started with this idea that you could
just start a scrape the web and news and blog,
but it became much more individual as sort of the advent of social media
occurred.
The idea that what one likes on Facebook or what,
when somebody tweets about,
uh,
someone searches about,
you know,
that becomes much more valuable information than just say someone posting a news
article.
And so our view of this idea of this sort of digital exhaust was that if you
could start to build algorithms that identified health related topics in these
sites and then started doing that across multiple individuals of a sudden now
you have not just,
you know,
mentions of events in a population,
but you have actually insights to people's phenotypes as they interact with,
with the web.
And I'll give you some examples from that.
Google flu trends,
Paul Paul Mention Google flu trends.
We are,
I was actually actively involved the initial concept and so there's,
you know,
controversy around the,
the platform itself.
But the reality is it was really transformational.
It really opened people's eyes to the concept of,
of a search query being something and a reflection of someone's health status.
And yes,
it had challenges because the models weren't being reevaluated over time as
people search behaviors change.
But the concept is still incredibly valuable.
And in fact it really created a whole new field of study in the use of search
query data for purposes of health.
And there are many,
many examples of how query data has,
has had an impact.
And we're still working with Google right now.
This is work with Google dot.
Google acts on some work around food borne illness post hurricane Harvey where
we're using specific search terms around gastrointestinal disease to track where
we might see the emergence of of outbreaks.
Of course following the hurricane,
Google of course not being the only place where you can get digital phenotype
data,
Yelp,
you probably didn't know 10% of all Yelp reviews or food poisoning related.
Um,
so we can start to scrape every Yelp review and start to get really interesting
insights.
This is from a particular area around San Francisco where we actually identified
particular restaurants and,
and in fact I'd started to identify ingredients that people were reflecting in
their illness.
And we did this on a national scale of course.
And then what we found was whereas people might think that consumer isn't smart
enough to understand what's,
what's sort of driving their illness.
In fact,
the ways in which in consumers talk about the ingredients actually reflects
almost perfectly well with what CDC reflects in their sort of the source of
every foodborne outbreak as well.
So a lot of really incredible valuable information to the point where we
actually worked with Twitter,
um,
to start to mind anytime someone mentions diarrhea.
Um,
and you might be surprised that millions of people tweet about their own
diarrhea on Twitter every year.
And so we said,
okay,
well if that's,
that's a source of data will will grab it.
And so what we ended up doing was creating an auto sort of essentially a mining
of anytime mentioned of a certain set of symptoms and then we have an auto
response that allows,
say a public health department to respond back to a consumer and then and get a
customized survey to collect much more data.
And you know,
our view of this is public health should be just similar to like United
Airlines.
We're reflecting back,
someone has a complaint,
public health can be reverted to respond to it.
And so we've been building these tools for public health agencies to really get
back in the game and we say putting the public back in public health,
there are many other areas that you can start to think about.
It's not just about infectious disease.
Um,
you know,
Paul again mentioned the idea of the FDA.
Um,
and absolutely,
you know,
when we think about the events that the FDA sees in terms of adverse drug
events,
it's a very small window into what's actually going on with individuals with,
um,
veteran experiencing issues with the medications that they're taking.
We get a very,
very biased sample.
Of course,
these,
most of it all comes from Pharma and life science companies,
but we know that there's a much bigger opportunity understanding what's actually
happening in the real world.
And we also know that patients aren't obviously that super active.
And even if they knew that their experiencing an adverse event,
they don't remember or they don't think to report that to the physician and the
physician knows about it,
they don't usually report it to the FDA.
So our view is,
well,
why not just go to where patients are already talking about these issues and
think about how to amplify the voices.
And so we built a VFD social media mining tool.
This idea that we could start just going to,
to the patient voice directly,
get insights about adverse drug events and start to provide important signals to
both the FDA and to,
to Pharma companies.
So again,
this is this idea of like how do you take a,
the way people talk about their interactions with medications and make it
valuable from an FDA and a regulatory perspective.
So you have to identify a drug,
a reporter,
uh,
you know,
a patient,
a,
an outcome and all of these things are actually identifiable even from something
as short as a tweet or a Facebook post.
Um,
and so all of that work can be done through the most challenging one of course,
is how do you identify people's outcomes?
Uh,
when there are many ways when people talk about the outcomes they experience
online.
And there's a whole effort,
and this is painstaking for years and years of work on the and human tagging
side.
And we could debate whether this needs to be supervised,
cost,
vacation or unsupervised.
We believe supervise does a much better job in the end,
even though it's a huge amount of work.
There's all sorts of things that we have to solve for typos,
which are kind of obvious.
But then the implied phrases like these are not things that are super obvious
when you were starting to mine this,
but these have to be tagged.
Um,
and then invented words and hashtags and all these other ways in which people
talk on the Internet are not things that you would ever see in an electronic
medical record.
So requires a whole new set of,
of analysis and of course spelling variations and Canadians.
So we use the U.
Um,
but you know,
again,
the idea is that we start to organize all these mentions and then we started to
combine them with more traditional classifications like snow,
Med and Metra.
Now all of a sudden when we're processing things like social media posts,
we have an ability to tag outcome and start to aggregate this across large
categories.
There are many other ways in which we can start to use these datasets,
this digital phenotype data.
Um,
we've done this a lot in the chronic disease space.
sleep deprivation being one,
a big topic.
Um,
when you go to your physician on an annual basis,
they may ask you how you slew asleep.
You're going to think about the past night and if you slept okay,
then you just won't really talk about an issue.
People won't really do a lot of sleep tracking,
although there's some interesting products now on a,
out there on the market.
But we thought to ourselves,
well,
why not just mine?
When people talking about sleep issues online,
and there's actually a huge amount of data,
people just disclosing the fact that they've had a bad sleep or they can't
sleep.
And what's amazing is you can start to track those individuals over time.
So you know,
their online activity.
You know how often they're on Twitter or on various social media sites.
So you actually know the time points between interactions on social media.
So you actually know if they got a good sleep or not.
And then we can start to look,
do case control studies where we look at individuals that are complaining about
sleep matched to people that have,
have not mentioned sleep.
And there's some really interesting findings that you start to get.
For instance,
people that tend to complain about sleep,
have less followers,
have much more negative mentions online.
So all the psychosocial sort of attributes.
Do you think about sleep deprivation all play out in the digital realm?
So again,
this idea of the digital phenotype,
sort of relating back to to what's people people are actually experiencing in
the real world.
We're spending a lot of time thinking about crowdsourcing and ways in which we
directly engage people.
Um,
there's advantages to thinking about how to sort of create participatory
surveillance systems.
So it's not this idea of just scraping people's underlying data,
but how do you actively engage people directly in,
in surveillance projects?
And I know there's been some really exciting work with fairly and the baseline
project.
And so this is maybe a more of a surveillance effort,
but it's similar in the sense of if you could start to build an incredible sort
of cohort of individuals reporting information,
you can get insights that would be very challenging otherwise.
And so this was actually also a initially funded out of Google flu near you.
This idea that um,
we could start asking directly people how they're feeling and if we can get
insights about sentence people are experiencing,
we can combine those symptoms to understand flew in the population because
there's a specific definition a for flu.
And so what's amazing is just building a system like this,
you can get 100,000 people just reporting on a weekly basis telling us how
they're feeling,
how their family members are feeling.
And there are also their vaccination status.
And so at that point you get some really interesting insights.
You can understand flew in the population or at the national scale,
which is all well and good,
but you can get other data sets,
you can understand sort of the demographic and age distributions and she very
granular geographic data.
And more importantly you can get vaccination status.
So you have an understanding of efficacy of the vaccine very early on in the
season.
And running a system like this really is,
is fractional compared to what it takes to run a true surveillance system at the
CDC where you're engaging with physician offices and laboratory facilities.
This is all,
you know,
very inexpensive and the amount of data you get is pretty incredible.
And the other side of it is that the individuals are being educated about the
importance of immunization.
And so you sort of have also the secondary benefit of tools like this,
which they represented public health education.
So we're thinking about how do you start to extend that because it's very hard
to get people engaged in a crowdsourcing tool to get PT people engage on a
weekly basis,
even if only takes a few seconds.
So we've been building tools at a of Boston children's to think about,
well what do people really want?
Well,
when I,
uh,
you know,
have a one or 3.4,
I don't really know what that means.
I have a set of symptoms.
What should I do?
Should I,
you know,
race into urgent care?
Should I go to the Ed?
Should I self treat?
But we have all these guidelines,
but they're in binders across the hospital and people when they come to the Ed,
there's some guidelines that exist,
but people don't have those guidelines easily available to them on the web.
They may go to web MD where there's no sort of decision support that's
customized to you as an individual.
There's very sort of generalized guidelines that probably all end up in cancer
anyways.
And so you want to think about,
you know,
where there'd be opportunities to customize this kind of information.
We built this tool that allows parents and,
and,
and individuals to understand what to do next,
what dosing they need to do.
But again,
in the and the backend,
we're collecting all this incredible,
get granular geographic data about health status that can help feed our
surveillance of,
of influenza
by extension.
Then we have these decision support tools.
These can then connect via API to a whole new sort of ecosystem of technologies
that are out there in the connected device space.
And you know,
my biases,
the influenza and infectious disease wrong.
But you can think about this in many other domains and connected devices where
you have a fitbit or any other device that you get some form of metric out of.
But there's not a lot of context to what that means in a clinical setting.
And so with a connected thermometer,
what we've done,
and this is one,
uh,
out of weddings,
um,
that essentially are now a Nokia,
I think.
Um,
but the idea is that you,
you take,
uh,
temperature and then that feeds you into their app that is connected via Api to
Thermia,
which is our tool.
And then you go through decision support that then tells a parent what to do
with their child,
with the certain set of conditions that they have.
So all of a sudden now it's a much more sort of personalized view to back to
that individual.
And we've been doing this across the whole sort of,
uh,
you know,
plot form of,
of applications and temperature sensing,
one off temperature sensing,
continuous temperature sensing tools that all of a sudden becomes incredible
data back into the system.
But again,
provides better information back to the individual.
And you know,
there's no,
you know,
it's always on one hand,
good to talk to this audience about sort of next generation technologies.
On the other hand,
you know,
I,
I need to be careful cause you I'm sure know a lot more than I do in this space,
but we've been thinking about all the new technologies and uh,
and,
and tools that are going to be out there for the consumer going forward.
And it's important for us to stay on top of it as a healthcare system and trying
to understand better ways to interact with patients,
better ways to collect data about outcomes.
And so of course,
all the new conversational interfaces that are emerging are ones that we think
are going to be playing incredible roles in interaction with patients.
It could be of course,
uh,
in ways in which it's more administrative.
Like how do I book an appointment,
uh,
with,
with my health care provider?
Or it could be much more educational.
Like I'm experiencing these set of things,
what do I do next?
And so we've been thinking about it and we've built some tools in house.
We've also partnered,
this is a company that spun out actually a out of Harvard medical school and
that I personally have been part of,
but also children's as a part of this is buoy.
There's several other companies in this space and this,
this idea of taking underlying medical knowledge,
pulling it together in a,
in a way that you have now a conversational interface that were the questions,
uh,
that come are not predetermined there based on your previous responses.
And the idea is that you get some sort of response back as an individual what to
do next.
So you're not interacting with an individual,
it's just purely a chat bot online.
But what we've seen when we've started to do this at children's is that there's
incredible value to be gained from it already in very early stages.
These algorithms show incredible diagnostic and triage,
accuracy,
triage,
accuracy being the most important for us.
We get inundated in the emergency department with acute conditions that probably
could have been cheated at home.
And so these AI based tools at the frontline can be incredibly valuable and
helping divert people to the,
to the right care,
whether it's stay at home,
go to urgent care or ed,
wait to call your physician again.
Now we have these,
these sort of first level tools that can help especially,
you know,
in in locations with a w that are resource poor.
Paul mentioned a voice and yes,
you know,
there's probably diverging opinions here about is it,
is it a gimmick?
Is that really going to be transformational?
At least at Boston children's we've been really thinking that voice is going to
be sort of the next wave of the Internet.
Whereas you know,
patient portals where 20 years ago and we're thinking mobile apps,
you know,
we've been developing those for for a number of years.
The idea that VoiceBase tools are going to play an important role in healthcare
is one that we're spending a lot of time thinking about.
There's all the data that's out there about how voice searches are going to be
ubiquitous.
That's a smart speakers are really already out there.
I mean,
we're not talking 10 years out,
you know,
many,
many households now,
a huge proportion of them have these listening devices in the home.
And so our perspective has been,
well,
if you have a device that's continuously listening and I know there's going to
be varying opinions about how valuable these things are,
it should be armed with the medical knowledge.
There's no reason why you can't ask questions that relate to your health care
personally or in general questions.
And so we've been experimenting with this pretty broadly at the hospital,
thinking about the applications in the home applications within the hospital and
then of course in the outpatient setting and just give you a few examples.
The idea is that of course in the home there's all ways that you can ask about,
you know,
we,
we've been thinking about how to ask about symptoms and other things,
but why not access your medical records or other types of information are,
of course,
people were thinking about this in terms of medication reminders and other types
of,
of tracking tools.
Um,
in the inpatient setting,
of course,
there's all sorts of ways in which we're actually already experimenting with
this and the hospital.
So the idea that a physician who needs to be hands free,
you can access all the medical knowledge of protocols,
the ability to page people,
huge amount of,
of things that need to be done in a fast paced environment that were voices have
we prime for and then the outpatient setting.
And this is one I think we're probably as the most conversation that's taking
place.
Why not have sort of a digital enabled listening device as part of the
interaction that a physician has with their patient that brings all that
conversation together,
codes it up and then of course brings it into the electronic medical record,
improves the interaction with the physician and the patient,
but at the same time,
you know,
is able to reduce a huge amount of the workload that our physicians are
experiencing,
which is pretty unbelievable at this point.
And you know,
we're not the only ones thinking about it.
We've actually been,
we just published a paper thinking about all the broad landscape of VoiceBase
tools.
Um,
there is an incredible array of technologies,
people thinking about this in the aging space.
People thinking about this in the dictation space,
many,
many different different domains.
We're actually running a whole voice healthcare summit in October.
If people want to come join that.
We have been working with Amazon now for several years.
Uh,
we built the first healthcare skill for Amazon Alexa called kids MD.
Um,
and essentially that's about just collectively putting together all the
questions that parents have to ask about their kids.
It's very early days,
it's improving over time,
but it was this sort of this use case like how do you start to use Alexa and the
way that it can arm it with information that's valuable to parents,
it's pretty,
pretty straightforward in the sense that how the skill works and how it
interfaces back with our,
uh,
underlying system.
We have a number of different tools around fever and asthma and,
and other,
uh,
other products.
I think the holy Grail,
and this is where I don't have a lot of data,
is more just a lot of interests.
So throwing this out there in case anybody wants to work on this project,
there is a huge amount of opportunity I think in the biomarker space.
I think that,
um,
if we can get over the concerns around what this means is,
uh,
you know,
from a privacy perspective,
um,
the idea that your volume and rhythm and on tone and all these various features
of your interaction with the smart speaker,
if that can be collected,
those have really important insights that can be gained.
Just sort of how search query data was incredibly revolutionary and still now
paying dividends in terms of research.
And I think the same goes for voice in the sense that there are many,
and this is already published data.
This is not just my,
uh,
my,
my prediction there.
There've been published studies and all of these different domains where voice
is actually contributing some insight and early detection to many different
diseases in many different domains.
So anyway,
just throwing that out there in case anybody's interested in collaboration.
The last thing I'll talk about is on the healthcare delivery side and,
and,
and sort of the last phase of where I think consumer technology plays a role.
We actually launched a product called health.
The health map.
Vaccine Finder are just maybe a couple of years after the,
the swine flu outbreak.
And in fact,
this is another example of us taking a product from Google.
I think now that it's happened three times.
Um,
so Google launched a product which is a vaccine finder tool to help people
identify what vaccines to get and specifically where they can get the h one n
one flu shot.
After the pandemic.
We ended up taking over the product and expanding it across a range of different
vaccines and built a tool that essentially has now every Walgreens and cvs and
Walmart and,
and mom and pop pharmacy where we have their supply information,
their pricing location,
all the data that an individual needs to make a decision on what vaccine to get
and where despite that being super,
um,
we think convenient.
You can't walk a block without getting,
um,
sort of an ad for a free flu shot,
it's still challenging.
So then we thought to ourselves,
well,
consumers are experiencing all this incredible value out of the on demand world,
um,
with Uber and Lyft and like,
why aren't patients seeing the same thing?
And so the,
our view of it,
I was like,
okay,
well why not start to think about flipping the script and getting these things
to the individual?
And yes,
now everybody talks about reification of health care and there are a lot of good
examples of that.
Um,
at the time I couldn't get Uber's attention on this,
but I actually wrote a complaint,
uh,
well I wrote in the box where you complain about your ride,
but instead of a complaint,
it was like,
ride was fine,
but maybe you should think about health care.
Um,
and somehow someone on the other end red,
they're like,
okay.
And then they came to visit us and we pushed them on this idea of flu shots.
Um,
and we got,
we convinced them.
And you know,
I know you people here understand how typical legal is.
So just think about maybe even worse,
I don't know.
But anyways,
just getting legal to,
to agree to putting a button on the Uber App though was about bringing needles
to people.
Um,
wasn't like necessarily the easiest thing to convince them to do.
But we did.
And we've done this for several years now.
We're putting nurses nuber vehicles and essentially you,
you request a vaccine on demand.
And it was pretty cool cause we were able to collect a lot of survey data and
show that people's decision to get a vaccine was heavily influenced by the fact
that it was on demand.
Uh,
that on demand was in a part of their decision.
And in fact,
many people never got a flu shot before,
but because it was that convenient,
they did it.
And so of course,
you know,
we're thinking about this broadly now.
Uh,
now it's been several years since we did this.
There are many companies that are thinking about logistics in health care.
Um,
you know,
of course it got mentioned Amazon and space to,
um,
we actually built a company out of children's as well called circulation,
which essentially sat sits between Lyft and Uber and health systems to help
manage logistics.
So the,
is that it's essentially an exchange platform where,
you know,
our view is that patients can,
should experience the same level of benefit as consumers do and round on demand.
But the current status quo for patients who can't afford transportation,
as they wait hours,
they have really inefficient ways of getting to their appointments.
This is all covered by Medicaid and they're insurers.
So we essentially took,
brought on demand and broad into the patient patient realm.
And what we've seen is really incredible in that there is,
um,
real huge amount of uptake and um,
health systems.
We're dying for a better way to help move their patients to their appointments,
but also how healthcare systems move there.
They're caregivers out to patients help her on product logistics or many other
ways in which sort of odd,
there are inefficiencies in the health system.
And so in our view,
there's this whole,
if you start to pull it all together,
um,
you know,
if you have this,
these constant listening devices in the home that interact with you and then
provide you guidance that all you know is great and that's your interface with
the health system and all of a sudden you bring in the logistics side and now
you've got the full,
complete circle.
Not only can you complete a visit and get insight,
but now you can get your prescription delivered to you and get even your home
care.
So there's a whole new world that's emerging just from the existing,
you know,
nothing incredibly innovative,
just existing tools that are out there right now.
Lots of challenges.
I mean,
we can talk about this as part of this discussion.
Uh,
you know,
we still struggle with this.
I mean,
I'm,
I've benefited by having a great collaboration with Google and others over the
years,
but of course that is highly variable for health systems.
Um,
it,
Bill,
I think there's Google cloud people here,
you know,
the storage ideas,
that still represents a real challenge.
And this is again is like a very sort of new field of study,
the digital phenotype.
How do you start to process that data?
How do you start to integrate that information with other sets of data?
It's all super early.
So we're having a lot of fun.
There were kids in a ketchup because there's so much in amazing data insights to
be gained.
Um,
but again,
how do you start taking all that insight and data and making it valuable from
the perspective of clinical care is still,
I think a little bit of a road ahead.
So I'll leave it there and maybe we'll have some discussion.
Thank you so much.
But John,
that was great.
Uh,
so encourage people to come up to the microphones to ask questions,
but I'll start off with one.
Um,
I think when you're very,
very close to this,
you can see the tremendous power of being able to gather this kind of
information that is outside the traditional sphere.
I mean,
we knew that most people don't spend their lives going to hospitals and clinics,
right?
So how can we understand what's happening,
uh,
in their normal life?
But when I have these conversations with people who aren't as close with,
they legitimately come back with like,
wow,
that sounds super creepy,
Paul.
Um,
any thoughts on how we sort of address this notion of there's some benefit that
this can be deeply unnerving and second in your own experience when Boston
children's,
like have you guys thought about how you sort of bring that information?
Then we often think about information or personalized medicine being really
about genetic information or epigenetic information,
but this is a different type of personalized information.
Where is there a mechanism that I could contribute,
you know,
information about my behavior or my social media activity,
may my physical activity back to my healthcare provider fascinated.
Since you're on the vanguard of this,
if you have any thoughts.
Yeah,
these are all questions that we get a lot of,
you know,
in terms of the acceptance of people that is,
when you've talked to the company,
is there maybe a high level people are thinking that's going to be,
you're getting a huge amount of pushback generally.
You know,
we've done huge amounts of surveys and capture data and generally people are
very excited if the data's being used for their own personal good or to be maybe
for social good.
We've had a lot of success and and almost actually I can't remember an instance
of any amount of pushback.
Of course the best policy is around patient consent.
So it sort of,
to answer your second question,
there's a lot of thirst around contributing my,
my activity data back into my system and that very easily comes with a
consenting or the data we're gonna collect via Alexa.
That again would be a consent issue.
Right?
So I think we can already solve,
even if there wasn't a concern to begin with,
we can start to solve it with,
with education and really explain to people,
you know,
what they're contributing.
And they have the opportunity opt out of these,
uh,
of these kind of assessments.
We're definitely spending a lot of time thinking about how to bring that data
into the Emr because again,
you know,
these data are siloed.
It's still a challenge like frankly getting the EMR vendors to,
to think about this data.
It's always sort of part of the roadmap,
but it's not sort of clearly,
um,
you know,
a big priority.
So we're having to build our own applications.
We,
you know,
of course I've been working with you for many years about using new data
standards to ingest information and build new visualization tools,
but it's still kind of clunky and not,
not optimize for real clinical use just yet.
Yeah.
Can you describe the fact that consumers have generally responded?
The question you're saying,
if this is useful to me,
I'm okay with sharing certain amounts of misinformation.
Um,
our sense from the part of the business that we work in with health care
providers is that many times the providers are so conservative,
they are afraid to experiment in this area.
How do you help them develop a sense of urgency around that?
We,
we definitely have a huge variation in our,
um,
physician pool around these technologies and datasets.
I mean,
when they're incredibly valuable and they create efficiencies,
um,
that's great.
Right?
Like,
so some of these datasets mean that that can reduce the number of physical
visits they needed to have with a patient,
right?
So it reduces the amount of effort over time.
That clearly is a,
when,
I mean we're spending,
and this is not exactly like the digital phenotype data,
but you know,
we're spending a lot of time implementing things like online virtual visits.
The idea that you can do like a of a virtual interaction with your physician
that cuts costs,
cuts time,
there's more efficiency when physicians see that it's,
it's a no brainer and I think that starts to outweigh the concerns of,
you know,
how,
how valuable that interaction was versus an in person.
Um,
you know,
that's sort of what we do.
But I think we have,
we definitely have a huge variation in an excepted.
Yeah.
So follow up on that one then of what you talked about was clinically oriented.
Yeah,
I think there are enormous opportunities from a business perspective in terms of
how data is used and measured and analyzed.
Do you get involved at all?
Do you and your team get involved more on the or at all of the business side
around things like a appointment scheduling,
uh,
telemedicine and things like that.
So our team is,
um,
focus a digital across the institution.
So those could be things like right clinical,
like say building a precision medicine service for the hospital,
but it could be just as easily like building virtual visit,
um,
or online second opinion program or building our patient portal.
Um,
so all that sort of in more admitted or appointment scheduling,
Doctor Finding,
you know,
all those things are,
are sort of part of the mandate of our innovation group.
Okay.
Last one.
Are you running a business in the children's hospital,
would you say and are you,
how do you think about contributing to the business success of BCH in
particular?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
there's been significant investment.
Um,
obviously I've got all my research,
I'd research grant funding,
but on the business side of the hospital,
absolutely there's a recognition that digital is going to bring costs down.
Right?
So,
and then there's also recognition that it's a must do from a patient experience
perspective.
Uh,
but then there's also a business side as well.
The Ip that we're generating and working together with companies has potential
value.
Uh,
we also run an accelerator where we're actually spinning off companies from the
come from researchers and clinicians identifying really important,
and I didn't have time to go into this in the talk.
There's a whole other version of this talk that is really about the accelerator
and all the various companies that were forming out of the hospital.
And that's a whole,
you know,
there's a business as well as mission case,
uh,
to doing that.
We have incredible data assets that also represents a business opportunity as
well.
So,
you know,
both in terms of us,
identifying opportunities to build things as well as partnering with outside
organizations to help sort of create some sort of funding back to support these
efforts.
You offered up a bunch of amazing examples of kind of infectious disease and
using big data.
I'm wondering if you can talk a little bit about heart disease,
which continues to be the number one killer in anything that you're working with
around heart disease and indicators.
It's particularly fresh in my mind is we just launched Google fit,
which is tracking steps as well as this new,
I think it's called heart points metric around and accelerated heartbeats et
cetera.
I'm so interested in kind of what you're,
there's a project in the space that,
I actually can't talk about it now,
but um,
generally I would say that hasn't a top top priority for us cause I'm in a
pediatric hospital.
Heart disease isn't always the right cause we're talking about lifestyle
factors,
but I think more generally,
I mean the idea that we can start to bring in tools that are,
are tracking sort of levels of activity and logging of,
I mean those things all relate,
right?
So we're building tools within our patient population that are sort of allowing
us to,
to,
to sort of catalog,
you know,
food and,
and other things.
I mean they're slightly differences,
of course it wouldn't,
things you want to track with with the child,
but they overlap as well.
Um,
but,
um,
yeah,
I'm trying to think.
I mean it's very different than an infectious disease disclosure.
I mean,
we've done things around social media where we've looked at heart attacks
related to people's disclosures of particular drugs that they've taken.
Like that was a big one for us.
We've done this in,
in,
in Twitter as an example where we looked at people's,
uh,
medication use and then we looked at outcomes where people reported having heart
attacks and we looked at associations and we've done this both in social media
data and clinical data sets where there's huge opportunities.
But,
um,
yeah,
I think,
but I'll have a study very soon to talk about it in this space as well.
Thanks.
Thanks,
John.
Thank you for your talk.
It was really great.
Uh,
you touched on this a couple times about the workload that doctors undergo.
Yeah.
Um,
I know that doctor burnout has been on the rise,
I think 45% to 55% last that I saw.
How do you,
does your team look at like the workload of data collection the doctors have to
do,
sitting there typing,
filling out medical records where you see the future of that?
Yeah,
I mean I think there's some really interesting companies start startups in this
space.
Um,
obviously I'm sure that there's some groups here that are working on that and
we've catalog this and we,
you know,
we do shadowing to understand sort of where the inefficiencies are and that data
side of it is really,
um,
becoming such a big part of the activities that a physician has to do,
which,
you know,
so again,
like we see it,
it's the number one complaint.
Burnout is the biggest topic.
It's one of our top priorities and the digital group now to solve.
Um,
you know,
I spoke about voice at the end and I think that again is where I do believe that
there's some real opportunity in the capturing of that interaction and,
and parsing of that.
Um,
I think obviously the tools have to get a lot better.
I mean,
nuance an example of a company.
So we implemented dragon.
If you're improving,
know if that software is just,
you know,
dictation tool,
we've seen tremendous uptake of that.
There's so much excitement about it and it has reduced workload.
And so now the next step is,
okay,
well what do we do with technology that can be sort of listening to the full
interaction that sort of,
you know,
go from a digital scribe to fully automated way of capturing.
I think that in my mind is,
is where there's a lot of excitement.
The other part of it is just purely around the Emr.
And I mean again,
I think this is where Google is super well positioned.
If you wanted to take that leap,
I don't know if that's ever going to happen,
but to build actually an Emr,
um,
the current ways in which the Emr is built is obviously on billing.
I'm not focused,
not really any Ui sensibility and I think that really is a big frustration.
So there's voice,
but I think just generally thinking about the user interface at that physicians
work with and where we actually have a project right now with verily that is
trying to focus on trying to extract information and reduce the amount of work
that a physician has to do to think about this sort of hit and medical history
of the,
of an individual.
So hopefully we'll get to present that at some point.
Thank you.
Thanks.
I had a question about the digital phenotyping.
I thought that was just a really interesting,
in terms of its applicability to understanding how to motivate patients,
particularly motivating children and teenagers.
I think that's,
that's particularly challenging.
So to what degree do you think you have insights on the phenotyping side into
how we deliver our care in a way that engages those pages?
And as a sub question to that also,
particularly I Linda mental health space,
right?
No,
I mean I think that there is been a lot of work really interesting startups in
the space and have thought about how to take,
collect that data on the backend and understand important changes.
Right.
It changes in sentiment and changes in the ways that people are interacting with
technology to create some form of learning.
And I do think,
um,
well we haven't done that ourselves.
There's some great opportunities around automatic feedback loops that they go
back to patients around sort of,
you know,
questions.
So you,
the algorithm detects a real change in behavior and that goes back to the
individual and,
and sort of as a series of questions to get a little bit deeper.
Um,
and I do think that there's opportunities to do this off of the existing
platform.
So you mentioned teenagers.
I mean this is where working with existing platforms becomes where I've focused
a lot of my attention rather than I'm trying to build your own new social media
tool for teens with mental health issues,
which really has challenges.
I mean,
people have tried these things,
but that's where like I think there's an opportunity for working with a company
like snapchat as an example.
Like why couldn't we have some form of,
of mechanism within those companies to work?
And then that becomes challenging,
right?
Like how,
like I've never as a researcher had an ability to do reach back.
Like I've been able to collect a lot of raw data and get insights,
but that loop,
I think that's where this group here is much more well positioned to try and
experiment with things that,
you know,
the usual research or just doesn't have.
Do you have any game of vacation experience?
Um,
not so much.
I mean,
I'm sort of on the fence on the,
and when we'd done a little bit with our flu project,
um,
with trying to keep people in the system points for,
you know,
the amount of reporting people getting flu badges and things.
I think they worked to a certain extent,
but,
um,
I haven't found them to be incredibly valuable.
I think there's been sort of over gamification in some ways.
We could have these tools,
but um,
we have,
we haven't spent a lot of time on that.
Well,
thank you so much,
John,
uh,
very much appreciate the sort of glimpse into the future and I'd like to thank
John for coming in.
Great.
Thanks so much.
Okay.